jinxy 1v1 bolo let's go yes you heard me
jinxy the screaming controller wielding
Tick Tock sensation who's taken over
Siege we just did a video on him check
it out challenged famed YouTuber turned
world champion bolo to a live streamed
1v1 you versus me Mano imano 1v1 tonight
and bolo accepted all right you know
what it let's go the two engaged in
a stunningly close Oregon boat that had
viewers on the edge of their seats until
the very end
is that it or
that operator is so cringe all in all a
riveting moment in siege that might be
one of if not the most watched 1v1s in
Esports history the score Esports is
gonna make a video on this I already
know the 1v1 that broke Siege